vient d'entrer gironde vient d'ôter
dépêche toi faut pas qu'on m'entende
je sais je devrais pas aimer la musique
mais c'est plus fort que moi j'ai la
musique danse encouragera mais rivière
les musiciens sont égoïstes et
responsable on a dit plus de musique tu
va écouter ta famille
pas de musique pense que nous sommes les
seuls au mexique a détesté la musique et
à des los muertos a commencé ce soir on
reste en famille des ancêtres serons
toujours là pour te guider si seulement
quelqu'un pouvait m'aider à accomplir
mon rêve
[Musique]
non
regarde chaque jeu doit rester avec moi
on ne sait pas où on est
[Musique]
michael lama imelda toujours aussi belle
fraîche que chaque alors séparé vous
êtes tous vraiment la bienvenue
rien à déclarer est bien comment dire
aussi
c'est l'enfant vivant
regarde ta main je deviens ce que tu
dois rentrer chez toi avant le lever du
soleil
le t d si vous c'est moi cocasse hommes
le budget n'est ya une chose qui fait
que je me sens différent et je ne savais
pas d'où ça venait on ne peut pas renier
sa véritable destinée
à toi maintenant de ces rachats
[Musique]
mais tu fais je mange comme un squelette
au passé inaperçu jamais vu un squelette
qui est cette démarche vous marche comme
ça pas du tout s'arrêtant dans ma
famille on n'est pas toujours d'accord
sur tout mais on reste soudé rien n'est
plus important que ce que vous aimez
[Musique]